in five four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
special quarantine episode of the genius
brain podcast man I'm back at square one
back in the crib Bay Bay you know how it
is very very nice
we don't do wardrobe changes in here you
guys are watching this [ __ ] they're like
they're running the same thing and nose
yeah exactly what it is but we're not
changing out of clothes because we're
just shooting these things back to back
while we have them Bay Bay yeah what's
wrong with that what's wrong with the
same clothes do you do you do that thing
where uh well first of all ever since
this whole [ __ ] should happen I'm
actually washing so much of my [ __ ]
clothes it's unreal yeah same here
my my yoga pants or like super afraid
yeah [ __ ] up so I'm trying to wear the
same clothes over and over just so I
don't [ __ ] up my other clothes cuz sure
every time I walk out I touch something
I come and take it off and I wash them
for him in the basket the same is your
bathroom right next to the door we have
it so what I do is I take it off I hang
it up she's all run so you take off our
clothes and you walk but make it to the
house deal with it my boxers oh yeah do
not hang it up and up there for three
hours because it's what it lives on
fabric for an average of about three
hours or less depending upon steel and
plastics the virus can last up to one to
three days and cardboard only an hour
hmm so if you get a package you leave it
out there for an hour you should be fine
well is that right [ __ ] Becca lying
to me what she says yeah we had a Amazon
package outside mhm and I think she
bought weights that was weights from
like Target and I was like oh did you
guys get a package cuz this is yours
obviously she's like oh can you put it
back outside it's only been good to keep
it for like four hours
no it's only now we just watched the
video yesterday where a doctor was going
through every [ __ ] type of surface
that it'll last on and they said
cardboard was about an hour right Chucky
yeah she says Muriel yeah so cardboard
is an hour cardboard but he was saying
some ridiculous [ __ ] he was taking that
not ridiculous but I guess like if we're
trying to be as precautionary as
possible the the do was saying that when
you get your groceries because
everything's wrapped in plastic you
don't know where it's been
leave it outside for three days and then
bring it inside three days you trying to
leave milk out
for three days but what are you talking
about me so what the whole thing about
like not wiping it down with like Lysol
wipes that doesn't I guess that might
work that might work too but it's hard
to get Lysol wipes as it is right now
yeah sure so I gotta order that [ __ ] and
then wait hopefully I'll come in like a
week yeah even I cost some part they had
I don't know why I'm thinking about this
but they have like it's big tub of hand
sanitizer then one of their customers
made for them I guess he's like a doctor
or some kind of like pharmacist whatever
but I was like was a 99% I was a 70%
alcohol she was like 99 I'm like because
99% like to the water solubility of the
water and the alcohol the water helps
trap the virus and like the alcohol like
can do its thing in this contained space
what 99% it's just like scorches the
whole thing Oh
virus can like to still live through
that it is you could go away from oh I
got lucky because I was doing sent foods
and then I bought like this whole box of
Purell alcohol wipes and I just been
using it for scent foods but we haven't
been going for it so I still have like
300 of those wipes left so when I go out
to the grocery store I bring three
walk-in when I walk out before I get in
the car I wipe my hands down go in and
wipe it out and then I'm pretty much
good my hands dry as [ __ ] though
yeah man as a dry it's super [ __ ] dry
people bringing him dermatitis
dermatitis yeah friend she's been good
in that [ __ ] or about to be she doesn't
take care of her hands she has I like
like a medical petroleum jelly to like
really yeah what the [ __ ] yeah but I
didn't know the dermatitis like your
hand starts to crack and it'll pus and
it'll blister and I don't know what the
rate but it's people don't know what the
exact reason is but I know that I think
I read it was like dude or like stress
is one of them is almost like eczema mhm
and then I can stress it's [ __ ]
disgusting yeah so on this episode of
we're gonna talk about another
documentary we on this documentary tip
man so is everybody in the world
everybody's talking about Netflix and
Hulu and Disney so why not us to Netflix
found the the formula it's it's
ridiculous documentaries that we would
have never known about that it's weird
because the stuff that you see in the
docks there on the local news or they're
there they're like televised like we
should have known about it like nation
okay we should have known about this
[ __ ] but I don't know if it's because we
become desensitized oh so when this
stuff pops up we just move past our way
cuz the movie so damn fast exactly but
if you guys haven't watched this [ __ ]
dude this is probably one of my favorite
documentaries I've ever seen in my life
shoutouts to Tiger King belly jugs oh
that's a tiger King belly I went when I
first saw the title of tiger King I
thought it was Bobby Lee special but
it's not it's is the most ridiculous
documentary about a bunch of people who
own a ridiculous amount of tigers in the
United States a bunch of [ __ ] ego
maniacs yeah not even just Tigers we're
talking about tigers lions whatever type
of exotic animal you can think of but
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] ridiculous there
are more tigers in captivity in the
United States than there are in the wild
yeah that's how [ __ ] many tigers
there are and the weird thing about this
that we found out was I guess like
there's a law that you can't import
Tigers but if they're already here and
you're breeding them that's whatever
yeah I guess it's not a sign of federal
law yeah yeah and you have to have a
license but people still do in the black
market to this day yeah and it only cost
like $3,000 for a tiger else I could buy
one right now yeah easy no [ __ ]
problem I could have a tiger right
[ __ ] now in my living room yeah Edgar
was kind of like that edgy wasn't very
interested in like the buying attack
yeah he wanted a white tiger I remember
he was so obsessed with that night I was
like I could buy one for like $3,000 off
the cargo ship and we could go down to
Long Beach other that drink weighs like
85 pounds what the [ __ ] is he gonna do
with the tiger dude you know air Jay I
seen the I see the [ __ ] edrick
sprained his ankle on a twig dude it was
so skinny he wouldn't be able to pet
that tiger would [ __ ] him up it would it
was [ __ ] insane
yeah but then we it was interesting
because when I was watching this
documentary
I first thought it was going to be the
way they edited this documentary was
[ __ ] hilarious - its money yeah it's
so [ __ ] money yeah so there's this
weird battle between these people who
are at the end of day it's about dollars
it's about money money money is God
not even in profit so the problem with
these egomaniacs is that they all have
this this idea that what they're doing
for their mo is that oh we're doing this
for the animals we're doing this for the
Tigers but the real thing is that
they're doing it either for personal
gain and glory or for a lot of [ __ ]
money so Tiger king is this guy named
Joe exotic Joe exotic is probably let's
say this I like using this example of
how ridiculous somebody looks if there
was a black dude I hated white people
and he was a cartoonist
he drew a white purse that's what that
white person would look like trailer
[ __ ] trash yeah to the tee he looks
so [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah he's wow you just yeah I've never
seen anything like a mullet so here's
the weird part of this guy Joe exotic
number one he's like I think he's super
right wing he's gay he loves guns
he owns [ __ ] Tigers and he's also a
country singer what I just found out
that the song spoiler alert most of it
isn't him singing what yeah most of the
song rate told me that yesterday -
that's right yeah most of the songs he's
just kind of like kind of like whispers
in the background like kind of like adds
a little vocal you know what was weird
because when I saw that right I was like
[ __ ] fire bro yeah he's good good I
was like this is dope when so he becomes
like the main person in the documentary
but it's kind of a link to all these
other people who own different Tiger
sanctuaries as well what was the girl
that he always was her well I keep I
forgot her name that he battles all the
time Carol Carol her name I think it is
Carol yeah I see Tiger King Carol she
was weird dude she's a matter where Todd
King is [ __ ] Carol Carol Baskin
that's her name Baskin yeah look at this
article says that she she rejects
Netflix documentaries portrayal of
herself
[Laughter]
Carol is supposed to be one of those doc
tiger sanctuary people that are actually
doing it for the Tigers but out of
everybody who does is she makes the most
money yeah she is ballin out of her
the the interesting part that by the way
if you haven't seen this doc don't
listen to the [ __ ]
just watch it please buddies this is for
people who have seen it or weren't going
to see it
Carol has this one weird moment in her
life where they everybody's personal
story is so [ __ ] weird
there's Joe exotic who is the the gay
Tiger Wrangler who owns guns and also
the [ __ ] Carol has this one part in the
in the documentary where they mentioned
that she happens to be a gajillion heir
and her husband who she gained the money
from happened to just disappear uh-huh
she [ __ ] fed her husband to those
Tigers it's not fact apparently you
better be careful man ser loras against
you [ __ ] her how about that Carol you
[ __ ] murderer you can shut you down
for for fact Carol you definitely fed
your ex-husband to a tiger well what did
they find out what did the lawyer say
that was really weird
in the end the will that she went back
and changed it from she added death or
disappearance or death and disappearance
hmm and disappearance like in that
lawyer
I guess the is you know nothing executor
I think was a lawyer saying like in his
378 38 years he's never seen that on a
will yeah well what would you write like
a last-minute change in a will and then
he just disappears he disappears and
then she gets 90% of the money yeah when
she she married this guy she was like 22
years younger than him or some [ __ ] like
yeah it was Susie some kind of crazy
double digit number that when I saw a
picture so if you look at a picture of
Carol she looks [ __ ] insane yeah yeah
she looks like a crazy person
yeah she looks like for a hot second I
got like a Mimi from did you Carrie show
oh yeah kinda I mean Mimi was a little
more extreme with her makeup and a blue
eyeshadow and stuff like that but carol
Basques and she was Oscar also crazy
didn't during that music video and when
he got the look-alike look just like did
he get these were crazy bows a
look-alike so the funniest thing that
you'll notice about a documentary is
that every person for some [ __ ]
reason that owns a tiger sanctuary who
loves doing music videos hmm
they love love doing music
and so this guy Joe exotic hates Carol
basket a lot because Carol and him had
been battling throughout this whole
legal dispute so he he became so [ __ ]
petty he took their logo like and
created his own entertainment company
yeah so it was like a copyright like big
cat rescue court versus big cat rescue
entertained just like so [ __ ] petty
yeah but he would put out all these
videos about how number one he would
call her a [ __ ] right and more than
that you could find I guess you could
look it up on YouTube and it's probably
all I don't know why I never looked this
[ __ ] up it's probably all on YouTube but
he was talking about like if I see here
I'm gonna [ __ ] murder her on sight
I'm gonna kill her and then he was set
up like dummies with her face on it and
the dildo in her mouth Oh Tom and all
his friends were like yo you need to
chill out dude you're gonna get she's
gonna catch up to you and the craziest
thing that this [ __ ] did was at
a certain point that their drama was
getting so [ __ ] crazy
he came back one day and his the shed
that had also there was a documentarian
that was with him prior to this to the
guy who documented this film that was
doing a reality TV show based on him hi
Rick something yeah and so he was doing
a reality TV show and he had compiled
about 5 years worth of [ __ ] footage
and there was a shed that had all the
footage all the equipment all the
cameras right and also all the
crocodiles in there that the exotic
animals that were also within this shed
and that's where they kind of stored the
equipment somebody as an arsonist burned
that whole [ __ ] place down now
interesting thing he is doing this video
talking about we are gonna find the
person who did this blah blah blah blah
blah
well the documentarian who was with him
all happy basically at all times they
were recording his life and that was
something that Joe xotic actually loved
doing Joe loves documenting his the
whole life he loves cameras every day
that he was awake he recorded his life
so for every day that he owned that
sanctuary there was a video of him doing
his everyday life so the thing that he
loved was actually the evidence that
damned him because there was somebody
with him when he was talking to like
some some legal me
personally uh that he found out that the
documentarian that was with him for five
years that was gonna create a reality TV
show based on him actually owns all the
footage that Joe doesn't own any of this
[ __ ] footage and so prior to that
place being burnt down he had a
conversation with the lawyer and the
lawyer goes and the lawyer was kind of
almost like hinting hitting like yeah
you got a [ __ ] burner that should be
and he's walking out upset like [ __ ]
this guy and he kind of alludes he goes
like so what are we gonna do he goes
well I'm gonna [ __ ] destroy that [ __ ]
hmm and then lo and behold what happens
arson arson
everything gets burnt down all the
equipment's gone
so this fool burned down his old play
own place and then he killed all of his
crocodiles just so the documentary
couldn't own five years worth that
footage just to be petty yeah [ __ ] in
sane and saying dude who's the other guy
they can think the god be the doctor
doctor he calls him doc he got himself a
doctor because he's like spiritual
sexual healing or something like that
the other tiger guy yeah was mean like
Bhagavan bhag bhag vidonne or somethin
doc doc doc I think was a doc the doctor
and tiger King he has like three five
wives or somethin yeah doctor Bhagavan
doc antal a doctor of [ __ ] mystical
science that's what he said that's
exactly what he is yeah he was an
interesting [ __ ] man dude like I uh
he was actually the only one that was
kind of coherent though yeah but yeah
like that like that we shouldn't trust
him really he's definitely most coherent
theory if you looked up I I went to a
state for a show once and I'm not gonna
say what the state is you guys know who
you are literally it's a stateful the
ugliest people I've ever seen in my life
oh my and I I have never in my life I've
I've never walked around with such
confidence in my life that I was a
handsome man and I just I looked around
and I was like I'm not it wasn't at the
college but it was just around and I was
like why do humans look like this oh my
god like
what in the [ __ ] there was a dude in
this documentary that he was an
informant he decided to go undercover
what the [ __ ]
he looks so [ __ ] weird weird the
weird [ __ ] bull cut yeah he was so
[ __ ] ah sure yeah there was uh so in
the documentary as well Joe he gets into
he actually loses his Tiger Tiger
sanctuary because he went into business
with some other guy who was also a
[ __ ] egomaniac yeah joe yeah joe joe
his Jesse Jesse
yeah Joe is Joe exotic is the oh and
this guy Jesse so Jesse starts to go
into a business with this other tiger
guy and open up a different sexuality
but he kind of [ __ ] him over that guy
is [ __ ] hilarious
I think the whole documentary it's
because the way he talks is the funniest
thing ever in his first interview I
remember this so clearly he goes he goes
well what do you want what do you want
us to do huh
Tigers are gone extinct they don't got
homes you gotta bring him he's a guy
that jesse was supposed to build that
new sanctuary with but Jesse backed out
and he was calling him up every [ __ ]
day getting pissed off at him he was
really this guy's really [ __ ]
aggressive he doesn't have that big part
of the doctor the documentary but every
time he talks he says the funniest
[ __ ] [ __ ] nudee if you guys watch oh
you have the glasses no you know there's
so many crazy characters
it's a [ __ ] whirlwind the characters
Joey exotic actually goes he you see in
the beginning of the doc that he's
actually in jail and the reason why this
fool is in jail is because he tries to
[ __ ] assassinate Carroll in the most
ghetto with Canton is it Carol Carol
yeah yeah yeah in the most jeaious way
possible he tries to get somebody who
was also I think he was like in the
tiger business as well and he tries to
get her assassinated for $3,000 puts it
all on text right and he's like the
biggest he'll ever calls up her husband
and it's like hey probably in his
regular [ __ ] boys hi
I got information about Joe exotic and
he goes oh really hangs up and they call
the FBI immediately before that he posed
on his Facebook he's like Vanna what the
[ __ ] lives oh my
he's so [ __ ] dumb it is a it is a
documentary about the dumbest most
disgusting man on earth so he has he's a
very ambitious person which I really do
appreciate about him he has a heart
because he dedicated a lot of his [ __ ]
to his brother who passed away oh yeah
really really cool but just to put out
how disgusting is the people who worked
at his Zoo they lived in the most
decrepit disgusting trailers like gross
I can't even describe how disgusting it
is wasn't that your paid like a hundred
bucks a week or some [ __ ] a week yeah
and eating Walmart meat yeah so he would
feed a lot of the Tigers like meat
but he would it's like expired meat from
Walmart or meat that would come in and
people return but they can't sell it or
put it back on the shelf so Walmart
would donate it to the tiger sanctuary
those guys would get first dibs before
the Tigers and eat the spoiled nah so
[ __ ] disgusting the pizza yeah the he
opened up a pizza joint at his tiger
sanctuary and guess what he used the
spoiled [ __ ] meat yeah I don't even
know if people ate the people coming to
eat that [ __ ] look like it it did look
like it yeah they might sue or something
no no maybe not I will say this though
the piece of fire the piece of [ __ ]
fire it look really delicious I wanted
some of that pizza then there was a who
else was in that documentary that was
him there was also the oh the how this
documentary even started was because
originally the documentarian was going
after somebody who sells exotic snakes
yeah yeah and that day when he was
looking to buy an exotic snake there was
this guy that was buying an exotic snake
that had a like a white like a leopard
or Snow Leopard or something some rare
ass [ __ ] feline in
hotman in like a 120 degree weather and
he goes this is a better documentary and
then he found him through that and they
started doing documentary that's how
crazy this guy's yeah damn there's so
many carry I lure just yeah you just
finished it so the campaign manager
my favorite dude my favorite like Steve
green I guess Steve had no aspirations
and he lived in a [ __ ] podunk
fucked-up place in Oklahoma that's what
Steven would look like I [ __ ] uh he
was the only sane person yeah cuz he had
like true aspirations like normal
aspirations I guess cuz he was
originally working at Walmart in the gun
department show comes in to buy some
bullets just that premise
[Music]
[Laughter]
Joe's like I'm running for president
he's like oh great I always wanted to be
a campaign manager he said a cool I hire
you and then he said it was the worst
job ever in his life
oh by the way Joe is a gay man who is
polyamorous so he had two husbands
mm-hmm
both husbands apparently we're not gay
yeah they just that's so [ __ ] that how
everyone is using each other yeah cuz
one of them was like [ __ ] the
receptionist in the front and the other
one was just like free meth and drugs
they were all [ __ ] meth heads doing
crazy meth together so one of his
husband's you'll see him in the
documentary he yeah you just assume he's
gait throughout the whole thing but
towards the end he goes up at night and
women my whole life since I was a
kindergarten all the way till high
school I was I was with women yeah it
sounds like so you're not gay
alright gay and this other husband was a
90 no kid from Southern California was
he yeah he's from California
damn not the one that yeah that nineteen
old kid Wow and then I think what they
were saying that he was just basically
doing it for free drugs and just get
being able to live with him to that dude
he had the biggest [ __ ] hands yes he
was huge big ass has size 16 feet yeah
he was he was like six foot six yeah
giant dude and it wasn't gay
he wasn't [ __ ] gay spoiler alert for
those he [ __ ] kills himself and it's
caught on camera yeah so they noticed
that he threw out this this documentary
is [ __ ] crazy yeah man I can't like
it's hard to it's hard to describe this
Dogma is so [ __ ] crazy it started one
of the things that I noticed was in the
doc they didn't have any personal
interviews of that husband really that
the one thing I'm sorry right because he
[ __ ] killed himself away there wasn't
any to take from him so he was showing a
lot of signs of like depression he was
being really weird they said that he was
just he the cat he would just walk
around point his gun doing that he said
what time he I woke up and he had a gun
in my face and so I guess that day the
footage that they have the cameras kind
of not faced towards him so he kind of
goes off camera and before he actually
shot himself he was pointing the gun at
the campaign manager they were actually
really close friends they became really
close after he started working for Joe
and then he goes he'll get that gun out
of my face like don't [ __ ] play
around like that he goes I'm gonna do
nothing and he starts swinging the gun
around then he puts it in his face mm-hm
and then boom boom bust his [ __ ] head
open with his gun right dies immediately
and the campaign manager is like it's
nothing like you see in the movies mm-hm
sat there with his [ __ ] mouth open
the whole time I didn't know what to say
that was a prank or something like that
he's gonna believe it just to show you
how hilarious this documentary is after
he dives they do the funeral oh and the
Joe exotic I he starts singing his
country music at the [ __ ] funeral and
he was making jokes yeah I was like dogs
Golden Nugget about did a eulogy about
his ball sack and how beautiful they
were ya know what I'm talking about I'm
sure everyone's seen his balls yeah oh
those beautiful golden Mitch
his mama's cried
this dude is he just killed him son the
funeral he's doing the eulogy and his
eulogy he just talks about his [ __ ]
beautiful testicles yeah you cannot make
these people up these are real [ __ ]
human beings I'm sure you all know about
his beautiful gold everybody salud
and then two months after that there you
go he gets married again he gets married
again to some other young man Dylan
Dylan Dylan he's gay for sure though
yeah this gives gay for sure he's gay
for pay yes yeah in love with him he
marries at two months later he gets his
ex exes or his husband who passed away
Travis yeah uh mother mother to come to
the [ __ ] money it's just her
yeah and hammer men in the camera man
that's it yeah enough that he never so
he was just she said that she felt like
she was used because he just wanted
proof that she had approval yeah that he
can move on and uh and so [ __ ]
garbage my guys [ __ ] oh did you guys
also know that he ran for the president
the United States that's what we they're
in the traffic Clinton this is recent
guys this is [ __ ] recent yeah so he
ran for president at swai minute he had
a campaign manager the campaign magical
friend to run for presidency mm-hmm and
then because he realized he wasn't gonna
do that he wants to be governor yeah
that was fun that was fun which was
[ __ ] crazy he's like you know what
we're gonna do to Isis the dummy were
like uh whatever that thing and then he
just blows it up he has a habit of
blowing [ __ ] up by the way there was a
part two where when Carroll was suing
him for a million [ __ ] dollars that
he had no assets he starts you know
obviously he's recording himself every
day and he just goes you want to get
what I have I don't have anything you
want my bed cuts to a seat and blows up
his bed my watch it's ridiculous yeah I
can't get my - those scrambled with this
so I it's weird because I know the
allure of wanting to pet a tiger really
mad I forgot where I was I think I was
in Japan and then they had this thing
where you were behind the glass and you
could pay to pet a tiger am i [ __ ]
this up with reality or is this a dream
because I feel like Gina was there and
then I think Gina was the one that told
me like yo they actually kind of drugged
him up and you know that's why it's it's
really inhumane but if Gina wasn't there
I would have petted that tiger I feel
like Gina did post him like that yeah
it's like super inhumane I'm not gonna
lie yeah that's what he did when he was
running what was it did he bring him to
like the Chamber of Commerce or some
like that yeah yeah to like he's also
magician too by the way was it oh my god
he was legit dude he's a pizza owner gay
gun right owner pizza parlor owner
Tigers a straight dude he also does
magic dude I can't there's so much
there's so much [ __ ] about this guy it's
[ __ ] unreal and then the other dude
who was the the doctor of mystical arts
doc antal he's also polyamorous he
hasn't launched it girls oh you know
that guy that I said I'll [ __ ] UM the
guy who who has said he was like no duh
he said something [ __ ] funny - he
goes when I met doc antal he was asking
me is like well do you want to learn how
to take care of cats he goes I don't
know how to take to get that type of
cats I'm trying to figure out how you
get [ __ ] to get [ __ ] because you would
have like four or five different hot
wives how are you talking about this guy
that guy was like a cult leader so there
was like women who would work for him
and he had a house for each each girl
that he was with I and and one of the
girls that was being interviewed she was
forced to get a boob job
got about her yeah she got it - she got
a boob job she got everything else and
she was a little weird herself yeah
and it's funny because she was talking
about how oh when I look for this job Oh
Craigs this one yes I know
the Craigslist people was the guy who
was a zuma-zuma jersey / he goes I it
was that really weird skinny guy with
the he was the one that eats all the
food from the from Walmart oh yeah yeah
yeah it was like when I looked up for
this job I found it on Craigslist
alright and I never done this before
[ __ ] yeah yeah and then he's the manager
of the zoom yeah just like that there's
another guy too
when you look at the documentary he has
to fake legs and I was like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] got eaten by Tigers and
there's like a lot of people think that
I got my legs eaten by Tiger zip-lining
accident and the busted his spine and he
had a butane his legs and there was the
other girl how do you remember all this
crazies it was so intense yeah
that was that one of the other zoo girls
she lost her arm one of the 100 yeah I
liked her she actually could have saved
her arm and she was so down for Joe
exotic so just to put this in
perspective there was a point where um
she got her arm mauled by a [ __ ]
tiger world is basically done but she
decided because she loved the tiger
sanctuary so much and she knew that
there was a lot of animal rights
activists trying to take down his
sanctuary that it was taken about two
years for her to rehabilitate her arm so
she could use it again or they could
have amputated it as she could have gone
home in a couple of weeks the reason why
she decided to amputate her arm and not
save her arm even though she could have
kept it was because that if she stayed
in that hospital a lot of reporters
would have came and they would have
dragged out [ __ ] on the tiger
sanctuary so if she if she caught off
her arm went back to work like she was
completely fine with it
it would have died down yeah and so she
sacrificed herself for that [ __ ]
sanctuary yeah that's how much she loves
that [ __ ] yeah she was brainwashed
brainwashed but you know she had towards
the end like when they interview her
because they asked her like do you think
he would have had the ability to hire
someone to kill Carol he was like no you
have any no didn't cut too so how are we
gonna kill her she carols on this route
he's take her out with a blow dart it's
like three thousand dollars yeah
three thousand dollars is like nothing
like I've never tried to hire somebody
to assassinate someone but I'm pretty
sure it would not cost three thousand
[ __ ] dollars
this podcast is brought to you by
molecule my friends have you in your
home had the most outdated air purifier
on earth that probably means you don't
have a molecule just to put it in
perspective what molecule is it's like
the Apple of air filters and I know some
of you are thinking I have a HEPA air
filter well what the hell did you know
that that technology is like 70 years
old yes it's that dated and molecule
don't play so why molecule global and
air pollution is worsening at an
ever-increasing rate over eighty percent
of people living in urban areas that
monitor air pollution are exposed to air
quality below World Health Organization
standards and this my friends is where
molecule comes in molecule air purifiers
destroy indoor air pollutants at a
molecular level removing them from the
air you breathe molecule uses Pico
technology to destroy VOCs bacteria mold
viruses and other pollutants that is II
mazing see pollen isn't just the problem
while it's easy to blame pollen for the
runny noses watery eyes mestizos it's
actually tiny proteins that break off a
pollen grain that are responsible for
seasonal allergies although less visible
these allergens can cause huge problems
and can pass through traditional HEPA
air filters molecule don't play that
game my friends molecule destroys
pollutants that other filters collect
customers who suffer from allergies
reportedly love their molecule since
molecule lunch we've heard hundreds of
stories from parents pet lovers and
severe allergy and asthma sufferers
about how molecule technology has
transformed their lives one customer
even says she was able to breathe
through their nose for the first time in
15 years lady what were you doing up
into that point you're just breathing in
farts to your mouth well now she could
bring it right in through your nose fan
tastic molecule got your back baby so
check it out if you guys want 10% off
your first air purifier order just visit
molecule as an m o le kul e.com
and check out by entering brain once
again for
percent off your first air purifier
order visit molecule M o le o le calm
and at checkout enter brain to get 10%
off molecule my friends get two air
cleaning get two breathing is so [ __ ]
dumb yeah three thousand dollars and
then he was like what what he's like I
just walk up to her in a parking lot and
the shooter yeah it that's the whole
[ __ ] elaborate plan mm-hmm-hmm I wish
I remember the name of the weird-looking
guy damn I that kind looks so [ __ ]
funny man I'm gonna be informant for Joe
exotic then Jerry no he was so
weird-looking if I just put fat weird
guy I'm pretty sure he would pop up Joe
exotic currently in jail right now he's
uh actually I did see someone on a
Twitter that he's still posting from
jail videos yeah so he's uh he's trying
to get a pardon from the president
oh my god yeah that we've pardoned Joe
exotic to be honest with you I actually
want him to be out of the ever since
documentary popped out remember that
music video
Joe exotic country music here
kitty-kitty-kitty-kitty since fire one
point eight million views now when did
they release four years ago it didn't
have one point in the eight I'm sure it
didn't because its documentary and
making money
this shit's so he shoots his own music
video the comments are turned off why
this is this is the caption for the
music video there's one way to get a
message across and that is with music
everyone loves music
this is his voice by the way it is
believed that in 1997 a woman in Tampa
Florida killed her husband in fed into
the Tigers in order to get all of his
property and money People magazine even
did a story on it has the People
magazine think enjoy the video and share
it with your friends in this world if
you could sleep at night and you have
enough money you can get away with just
about anything
well that's how much he [ __ ] hated
Carol thanks lady everyday here we go
guys
turns out this is not his actual voice
[Music]
yeah I thought it was him singing - and
it's not even him saying to you I like
he's such a good singer and he has like
the fake Carol feed her yeah me feed the
bloggers yeah this was [ __ ] likers
mannequin he didn't like risk because he
thought he could actually replicate or
create the new saber-toothed tiger
that's what I read that's why he did
that she doesn't believe yeah but like
herbs get big man huge like it's 10 11
feet yeah I looked it up a while ago to
is like 11 feet we can get to like dude
11 feet 11 feet like 800 plus 2 like a
thousand pounders of insect huge there's
a there's a picture I saw back in the
day feeling a liger
and it's like him standing up on this
thing and their feet above a house
[Music]
[ __ ] 11 feet tall a liger dude Liger
sighs let's look this [ __ ] up right now
dude how much those guys around 11 so I
was a little little exaggerated for me
so like is way 800 to 900 pounds twice
as much as lions and tigers and are
around 11 feet long and five five feet
tall so just the body alone without the
tail was [ __ ] five feet dude that's
[ __ ] gigantic yeah we're going back
to all that it's just like you just it
stuck that it sucks that the Tigers are
crop and it caught in the crossfire is
with this yeah like this the breeding of
them nexus of breeding and then knowing
that like the rumor about like where do
these Tigers go because yeah he says I
got 228 tigers on my farm like how do
you have 228 tigers I'm sure you don't
see them all
at once yeah but at one time probably
you did or maybe that's how are you how
much you've had up to this point but
where did they go like you sell him off
but then there was that rumor saying
like a tiger cub is no good to you after
like six months or something thing
because after that that's when the
upkeep and all that [ __ ] so there was a
rumor that he was like killing them and
like having mass graves oh that's right
he actually killed like they they found
like six Tigers that were buried in his
property yeah and he just here like
random shots in the middle of the night
he said that he euthanized them or some
[ __ ] like yeah yeah they were sick or
whatever but cool really [ __ ] those
yeah
in a lot of places I'm a member this
summer too like a lot of places donated
or do I guess donated and like they're
not that's not the word but people will
give them horses oh yeah yeah oh yeah oh
that's right they would donate like cows
who just died and then that the tires
can chew on them or [ __ ] mark I mean
she's just like pulling that [ __ ] like
Flintstones and like dance is some crazy
backwards do you remember the part where
he got attacked by one of the [ __ ]
Tigers ah you dragged him by his place
I'm gonna book a load on my shoe oh
that's scary but he shut the [ __ ]
tire yeah you shut down the floor oh man
I think I scared and then they're
walking away and a couple couple you
ever remind me up but remember that
scene in Lion King where the hyenas were
going after scar oh yeah the Tigers and
the Lions were like yeah yeah and they
say she shot he shot like four or five
more shots just getting them away he
goes I swear to god I'm gonna put this
right between your [ __ ] ass
yeah you [ __ ] yeah just like what
that Titan was dragging him by his
[ __ ] yeah dude you gonna lost his
foot yeah he [ __ ] did the splits and
[ __ ] that is the definition of [ __ ]
trash those are the most trashiest
[ __ ] human beings I have ever met in
my life dude I said where do you find
somebody who almost got paralyzed from a
zip tie the accident and here's to fake
leg it sustain it for I don't know how
many years they've had it for but it
seems like they've been running the
operation for a very long time like I
still don't understand cuz Joe
saying like I don't make money off of
this and then you see his living
conditions like does it really I mean I
believe it
I guess like ah does all the money go to
the Tigers and upkeep and cuz it says
like ten thousand dollars a tiger a
tiger just I feed him per year a year no
wait really I don't was a month Oh was
it a month yeah this is the the picture
of the like yeah oh that's what's his
face that's the the doc Ethel dude
that's doesn't that crazy like I've seen
this is the picture that I saw here yeah
and this is mental Wow that's the
[ __ ] guy well in that [ __ ] look
how huge this [ __ ] is Wow that's
beautiful
they can't fight there they're like
donkeys they can't reproduce right right
yeah if I don't have like a long
lifespan because of the organs why
because they're so [ __ ] gigantic yeah
they're not meant to be that big you
know I always think these animals are
cute until I go to a zoo and I see them
in person
and they're [ __ ] frightening yeah like
the Tigers head is like the size of this
[ __ ] table
it's disgusting number I should that
picture so we were before we were
quarantine cliff and I were walking with
our buddy ray and there was these kids
that were walking by it's very beautiful
day the kid walks by he goes but he says
what do you say about the bear he was
like I could take a pair down yeah
something like that
our bears aren't scary or bears aren't
you could take on a bear right right
yeah I could probably fight a bear and
as that was I you think you could fight
a bear I don't think so he goes yeah I
can but just just the distant a before I
saw a picture of a man who shot a bear
I'm not sure if they were hunting or
what whatever was going on but there's a
picture and a video of him getting his
face mauled off I I'm not even [ __ ]
kidding you it looked like some [ __ ]
from like Kill Bill yeah but his one of
his eyes were ripped out his whole face
when I say whole face I'm talking about
from one ear to the other ear was
hanging off and all you see is this meat
on the inside shredded and one eyeball
and he's talking to the camera
yeah go ahead hear him I can't believe
that you can actually can understand
what the hell are you saying
I think what happened was like the meat
that was hanging over was covering his
mouth so his mouth was still
[Music]
it likes either swipe that his face or
bit try to bite his face off and he
survived that [ __ ] this little kid was
like yeah I could fight a bear I wanted
to stop him feeling little bit show
watch this this could have been you
I have coronavirus when we were walking
to there was a Adam I think people in
South Pasadena there's such nice people
there they're hearing all these articles
about Asian people having hate crimes of
[ __ ] so every time they see an Asian
person they're extra nice you know like
yeah yeah there's an extra nice you know
they're like good morning iContact how
are you yeah oh my oh so you had to make
sure that we're not wanted vamp yeah
yeah so I this what black people go
through huh do you see that one white
person that tries to be extra nice to
the black guy yeah I feel like that now
right I'm getting racially persecuted
and but the people who are really ultra
sensitive they're doing a little too
much yeah yeah it's funny it's funny
like it's like you know he's in that
black person like that's the stereotype
if you see a black person on the street
and he's terrified you cross you cross
the road across the other side of the
street now before like I guess one Trump
whatever double down was like China
virus the tired virus thing and then he
went back it's like we cannot treat our
Asian Americans like this is not right
hmm and now but before that people were
crossing the street when they saw an
Asian like oh that an Asian girl saw us
and the cross the street
this coronavirus got people's racism
[ __ ] I know it's crazy because people
the you you you think racism is gone
it's so apparent dude it's it's hyper
apparent especially in comics in the
[ __ ] that I read it's it's not even so
much and this is why people I think
dislike Trump a lot is that a lot of
people had their racism in check right
even if they did feel this way there
wasn't this like huge community that
wanted to come out and speak out against
certain races or certain ethnicities but
because their president is at the
forefront of it they feel empowered now
and you've been I don't know if it's
because it's my personal like
confirmation bias where I just see it a
lot more now where people are writing
these racist [ __ ] comments on every
[ __ ] things like you gooks you chinks
or what
even even especially like with uh I
forgot that was like a video where they
were it was like some races just
occasion people right it was a black guy
doing it but then every Asian person
white person Mexican person were in in
order to counteract that racism from
this one [ __ ] up individual we're
saying the most racist black [ __ ] I was
like damn dawg so what you always fill
in that way or what what's it really
about right which is which is just a
really sad thing to see I'm like can't
really blame a whole ethnicity for that
one individual [ __ ] right but you know
people's true colors are showing you
yeah it's scary dude
it's scary it makes me think about my
mom and all stuff and just people acting
reckless dog your mama is your dad's
black your mom's Asian you got the two
most wanted people say home please all
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are just chilling
out there life cycle it is not your turn
9/11 no more coronavirus now take it
yeah that's just [ __ ] crazy man it's
really ridiculous though I I uh I get a
little sad when I kind of see these
videos but it's I haven't seen it happen
to me you know and I have to just make
sure that I'm not insensitive to it
because I think a lot of the times when
I don't see things for myself it's hard
for me to get too emotionally invested
into it I see these videos I get sad I
get upset but yeah I have I it would be
more tangible if I saw it so like yeah
my upset meters at like 50% but if I saw
it happen in front of my eyes that's
when it becomes like really [ __ ]
unreal but then I think because we live
in South Pasadena everybody's like that
yeah everybody's going out of the way to
be super nice right now right right
right like hello may just [ __ ] slant
their eyes for me that's actually bad
race no I do definitely I definitely
agree with that too cuz like I think
we've just been fortunate enough to live
in a city that is a little woke or I
don't know there's nice people just nice
people in general I think for the most
part yeah for all parts really but when
I do hear about they you know at that
correspondent that heard someone on the
White House one of the White House
officials say
that they call it the conk flu virus and
then Killian Conway was like that's not
right I don't agree with that but tell
me who said that yeah and she couldn't
say who officially who really said that
I'd be curious to know who really
because if the reporter saw that person
she wouldn't have to know who that
official is to like out that person but
that never came out
I don't think I might be wrong baaz like
that's true because it's such a it kind
of reminds me and I'm not I am comparing
it but I'm not like Jessie Smollett like
he's just new like you know with the
cops killing black people and like Trump
and the just the rhetoric he's been
spreading and spewing like he needed to
capitalize on that to keep it going and
so II you know [ __ ] fake juicy
sommelier
do you see small yes you see sommelier
had to fake his you know his his assault
to feed fire to the and you couldn't
even use two white people you got to
African dues to do it I know you make
them look bad now it's like damn bro you
just yeah you [ __ ] up but I almost had
a slight feeling of that when I read
that tweet the logistics movie I think
huh yeah yeah that almost had that with
this reporter who was it tell me I have
no idea what a porter was no I'm like
she should say like who it was who was
exactly you know who is just call him
out but maybe it wasn't somebody I don't
know I'm I just I'm so caught between
like 50 percent like if I like you said
if I was in the presence of someone with
my mom and I'm walking out and there
call my mom like it's because you the
virus is here like then I'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah you know but it's a lot of you know
one could say anything on Twitter and
like someone liked it and then
immediately turns into a viral people
people might [ __ ] hate me for this
but when I read that tweet
I had never laughed so hard in my life
come flu is hilarious when I read that
[ __ ] I was like that's offensive but I'm
like that's [ __ ] funny yeah if
somebody came up to me and they're like
[ __ ] you got that come flu I would have
I would have been my I'm a sock you
first but afterwards I'm gonna die
laughing you're hilarious I would have
wish I would have put that in my [ __ ]
stand-up set a kung fu is [ __ ] funny
pretty funny but then like you know the
context is not funny but when I first
read I started giggling
that's [ __ ] good Matt goes out of
that I would have never thought of that
[ __ ] come flu virus right and it's just
like jokes just like you know what that
was that [ __ ] Wilin out that would be
some [ __ ] someone would say yeah you
know it was like it's like it was like a
rapper dis yeah yeah there's a fire ants
bar I was like hmm interesting
kung flu who sent that [ __ ] to me and I
and I wrote lol exclamation exclamation
and they wrote back it wasn't supposed
to be funny you send it to the wrong
person dude yeah that's [ __ ]
hilarious that like it wasn't supposed
to be funny I was like yeah but that
[ __ ] hurt my spirit dawg yes [ __ ] up
yeah I wonder if yeah I do start to like
question a lot of that stuff now because
sometimes we just get caught up in the
hype a lot of the stuff I do though is
more like hypothetical if that's why I
try not to get too caught up in [ __ ] and
if I do I get too overly emotional but
stuff that I don't really know about
right the whole story yeah cuz like that
juicy small yay thing was the biggest
yeah he had all black Hollywood tricked
he'll everybody came up is supported him
you know who didn't believe it though Oh
Tim really thanked him and Rick said
like mmm this sounds a little a little
odd it's like what and the reason why
only reason why I thought it was odd I
was like what black many subway black
homies ever ate subway at night destro
you [ __ ] kidding me that's the most
we did it we didn't know we lived in
k-town during the day [ __ ] yeah we only
ate it we only ate the specials during
the daytime you as a black man David we
only ate the specials and Wednesday was
my favorite because they had Turkey
because it was low in calories you did
get that a lot yeah they told me the
bread out too cuz I thought it and I was
like the fattest at this point in my
life and you were on that I forgot about
that
dan used to eat that [ __ ] all the time
yeah Dan head Dan and Edie a [ __ ] sub
water
yeah that's subway next to 24 I was
[ __ ] the same [ __ ] guys well that
wraps up this episode well of the genius
brain podcast yeah yeah man make sure
you watch that Tiger king
you'll watch ty Lee's watch it it will
make you forget what's going on in the
world I yeah even even if you hurt this
and I'm spoiling this [ __ ] for you I
missed a lot of stuff but you just have
to watch it because it's probably one of
the best stand-up specials yeah there is
so much like I've been so many
constipated I'm so surprised you
remember so much [ __ ] like he's like
David said there's so much that we
missed that you should need to watch it
it's a seven part series it's almost so
ridiculous it's like it's it's like I
watched six seasons of this is us yeah
what the just batch it keeps happening
over and over and over
yeah it's worth the binge if you have a
negative feeling about binging this is a
show to binge us just watching a train
wreck like the front of your face the
case of Gabriel Fernandez is hard to
watch all the way through because of how
emotionally exhausting this is but it's
in very informative how the system is
working if you want to go into that and
be more knowing of what's how that works
that's a that's a good documentary to
kind of get a good grasp of the LA
County Ellie's yeah I found that
operates with the DFCS
or whatever that was it the Department
of Department of Children and Family
Service so much that yeah yeah but this
one's more like you'll just be cracking
a throttle yeah and that's what we need
right now yep
anyways guys you guys why people wrap
now [ __ ] Popeye hey you catch us on
all audio platforms you can see us on
Spotify iTunes if you're on items give
us that five star podcasts are up every
Thursday and Sundays this podcast is
about everything and anything and we're
just here to give you stupid
conversation on the way to your commute
to work that you're not going to anymore
because of the virus so thank you guys
very much we'll see you all next time
he's O's brain piece Oh what can they
find you oh you can find me on instagram
Khalif Boyd Killeen Boyd check him out
that give him a follow there be seeing
him here on quite more often so yeah
yeah I talk can you believe that
alright y'all peace